Why do you think of two more
speaking with graeme dunstan.
And i'm graham dunstan i was the director
of the aquarius festival in 1973.
And i came back to nim and as an im
and resident between 1974 74 and 180
and worked on community
development in them
but so i have an intimate
association with the post aquarius.
Community development there
and then how did you come to
be involved in the areas.
We know. Goes back to.
The beginning of the sixties
and i went from school in the
duntroon as a military cadet.
And i became very disillusioned
with what was happening as a cadet.
In the army just worked out that
the army wasn't for me this is
that the time of intense bastardisation.
Initiation the same time the university.
That duntroon try and become
an academy and grant degrees.
So i wouldn't want to get it to have.
Academic training and that same time
your life was run by drill sergeants
and most immediate concerns
was polishing your boots.
So i feel sort of distinguished
myself academically
but had increasingly problems became
the most punished get it done through.
And during that time was under a lot
of pressure to resign and get out
and i was hanging in there so i could get
the academic qualification would give me
some exemptions at university.
And the university at peered to me
then to be some sort of salvation.
Like my ideal as a place
i really wanted to be.
And so it was
that i enrolled at university first at
melbourne uni university for a year doing
engineering.
And i was approached by asio
and asked to attend meetings.
You know to see what had happened was i
thought well i've got all this military
training want to do with it
and so i applied to join the squadron
university squadron and hope
that i'd learn to fly and i was rejected.
But they say we've got something
more important for you.
You know approached by these two guys
from a zero saying we want you to attend
meetings and give us reports
about what's going on
and being straight out of the army
and straight out of school having
no political sophistication at all.
I said well it sounds like to me i wanted.
I want to go to these meetings anyway.
So i became my regular lunch time at the
university not to sit with engineering
students down the engineering faculty but
actually plug into all these meetings
that were happening.
And of course the more meetings i tended
to the more interested i became in the
agenda of the left
and particularly the information about what
was happening in southeast asia because
i had some inkling in this one
as a duntroon they were already.
Briefing us about south east asia
and preparing officers for
a south east asian war
and part of the tension with duntroon
was they changed the conditions
that they announced
that they weren't going to accept any
more resignations of officers they were
actually going to build
up the army at that time.
So if i said
that the commission after duntroon i would
have been in for a lifetime was what
they were telling us. And.
So i thought well this is the other side
of the coin finding out from the left.
What's going on in southeast asia.
The year after i did one year at melbourne
university then transferred to the
university of new south wales and.
Again attended meetings got very
interested in the labor club
and the difference between
the university new south.
Wells
and the university of melbourne was university
new south wales the very new campus
in the didn't have the
infrastructure of student clubs
and societies at the old university had
so i felt behove the start creating it.
So i started organizing my
own meetings my own talks
and again i was approached by a
cio and to get back into it.
I think i had about four
meetings at this time
but eventually i was elected
president of the labour club
and i had to tell as i was too compromising
to be president of the labor club at
the university new south
wales. So i became.
Thanks to the initiation those you
know offered me a very active.
Student organizer and involved in
the initial moratorium initial.
Teachings and inviting people to talk
about what was happening on the campus
and from the labor club they
became present the student union
and entered the student newspaper.
Full time student activist along
with a full time engineering degree.
And.
Became one of the principal organizers
of the protest movement on the campus.
I came back to the i
graduated in 1967 and.
Work the next year. 68 full term.
I was a country member i had a job
as a computer programmer for a while
and then came back to
the university in 170.
To do a degree in sociology
and was again invited to re-engage
in student politics and
that was the year of the when
he bagan editing at the rank
and i was the director
of student publications.
So i was right back in the
thick of the organising and.
By this time i got to appreciate this.
These were the moratorium
years got to appreciate that.
What was really working with the anti-war
movement nanny conscription movement was.
Not so much giving people information and
talking at people for public meetings
but so
but more the the cultural movement the sense
of every time we had a protest in the
street it was a festival. So this time
was sort of introduced to the king.
And i think one day at the sort of statement
about the power of joy caught my eye
and i began to realize that the way
you can create cultural movement
and remember as doing sociologist was to
create events where people sheer joy.
So i got very interested in this strategy
and whenever we organized an event on the
campus we'd always do it with a band.
It was like a celebration. So i
got very interested in festivals.
In 1971 the aquarius foundation of the
australian unionist dude nsw had a
festival i think was the first aquarius
festival on the campus of the university of
a and it was a in the national
australian national university.
And this was an extraordinary
festival and i went along.
And was delighted
that at the the activity because students
come from all around australia at this
time the australian union of
students was a very strong union.
It had an escalating membership
as more cias were brought online
and sort of welcome into the fold
and every student was paying
50 cents to be a member.
So it had a sort of an increasing budget
and had more and more departments
that was opening up. And the australian new
students at that time was responsible.
It had travel france
that it sort of taken off like a rocket
its abs goal department which was
regionally about raising money to get
students aboriginal students through
university it had picked up on
the land land rights issue.
The education department was writing the
agenda for the labor party the education
agenda for the labor party
international apart
and all these kind of things happening.
It had been an organisation that.
I've listened to being under control
of the cia funding and stuff
and it sort of done this huge turn during
the late sixties and early seventies.
And one of the things that it created
was a cultural arm and the idea was
that the aquarius foundation would be
responsible for campus tours of artists
and speakers and it was a vision of
this sort of national organizing body
and then every two years it would
organize a festival which was originally
conceived of as being
bringing all the end.
Into varsity groups together so that
all the dramatic societies would come
and perform at this festival and all the
debating society would come. You already.
All the dramatic societies
and all the debating societies the corals
the sides would come together in one
place and have a festival or when
they came together it a new in 1971.
Something else spun off the synergy of
the situation was having all those.
Embassy is in symbols of authority.
The students were extremely reactive
and like every day a protest would be
organised so that. The four meant of the.
Of the the festival wasn't so much around
the programme of events which was quite
interesting in itself but
the student activity
that arose spontaneously from all these
student activists coming from all around
australia to one place.
Now i was greatly stimulated by this
and utter overturned the sydney.
I had a meeting with johnny allen
and johnny allen was an old
friend who had been doing.
Arts a drama degree at the university
and i'd known him through his.
Theatre organisation
and he'd after leaving university had taken
up an organized among other things the
sort of the arts factory in surry
hills which was like the first rock
and roll venue
and was very interested in organising
festivals countercultural festivals.
In 1971 i got to say i was editor of
the university paper against the ranga
and i was running it on the theme of the
counterculture had been greatly influenced
by theodore rose a book called the making
the counterculture so i was looking
around to see what sort of changes were
coming as a result of the impact of the
anti-war movement to conscription movement
what sort of cultural things were
arising
and each edition of the paper each week we
would produce invite a guest editor in.
And explore a particular theme so the
themes typically were anti-psychiatry.
Ecology health foods spirituality drugs.
Such themes such they and i had cause to
talk to john allen about some of this
and we had a meeting which was a day.
Why have all places and johnny had
been at the chorus festival in a day
and you too. And we sort of sat
down compared notes and both agreed
that it was an extraordinary event
to bring students together this time
and probably the program was
getting in the way at the festival
and wouldn't it be a great idea if we
would organize a festival of students.
And not have the standard arts program
but rather take the festival away from a
university where it had all those symbols
of authority to react to and ask the
question what are we for right.
Make it a lifestyle festival
and put the question to people what do
you believe in what kind of future.
Do you want to create.
Well we walked up
and down the street the beach talking about
this wonderful thing we finished with
agreement that i would write an
article about it for the australian.
You know australian university student
australian unionist tune. Yes.
Publication called national you
which i did and it was published
and i forgot about it and done that
and in one hundred seventy two.
I was teaching blacktown boys high school
when i received a call from the organizers
of the aquarius foundation saying we're
advertising for the
festival director for 1973.
We really like what you
wrote in the paper.
Why don't you apply and i think
teaching was going really sour.
And i put in an application.
And was flown to melbourne and interviewed
and at the time the australian union students
had invited ivan ellicott for a sort
of a tour and i have an elec as a sort
of third world philosopher about.
Going to say development in the
third world alternative options
and particularly de
schooling and those kind of
and i was sort of blown out by the ideas
that this man was coming up with and.
It was after one of his talks that are.
I heard from the interview on
committee that i got the job and
that also they said we'd also interviewed
for another position the directors
aquarius foundation
and do you know a fellow called
john allen he's also from sydney.
So it was like fight through us together.
He was johnny on the ground dunstan
appointed to the only two positions in the
aquarius foundation only to paid positions
to organise among other things the
aquarius first of the 1973
so we had a blueprint.
Already worked out and then we
had the job of putting together.
There are two things
that were required for
that one was to get the
message across to the people
that they should come as tribes
and bring something to present to
the festival not we had this thing
that this is not a consumer festival
you have to make this festival.
So if you got a particular thing you're
you're presenting like the alternative
community telephone at that
time was hot in sydney
and it was like an information center.
Service run by stephen wall and and.
And horan walker. I forget the horror
and horror and but adelle horror.
And we asked them to help
us publicize the festival
but also bring up their ideas
about community and the festival
and bring their ideas about communications
and so they did eventually they were very
helpful distributing information about
the festival and they came as a big tribe.
Festival and also another
example would be.
The feeble foundry gravel street paran.
Sort of a whole wholemeal bakery
that developed the it was also kind
of the community center and tribe
and they agreed to come
and not only come there bought
their bread making techniques
and took over the neiman bakery and they
bake the bread for the festival and
that was the kind of reach.
We the message we wanted
to put out to people
and the other issue was like
finding a site for the festival
that wasn't a university campus
and wasn't in an urban center
and place where people could camp
and reflect inward rather now.
And that was my job to find a site.
And we we reasoned
that the southern states were too cold
queensland was too hostile politically
and sort of the the northern rivers area
the north coast of new south wales seemed
like the best bet. And it also
had a mythology going for it
that we'd heard about this mythical place.
Surfing paradise called byron bay
and there was something happening.
Behind marlon bimby
that were rumours of so we set up
set off to explore this area and.
I advertised in the local papers for a
suitable simon kind of looking for you know
300 acres or something.
You know ideally countryside which might
become a community after which the
festival would leave something substantial
after it. After we had it. And i had at.
No response.
No one answered the ads and i travelled
round to go around real estate agents
and i was getting exhausted
and consuming lots of petrol.
Burning up lots of petrol driving around
the north coast looking at properties
and we were running out of time
it was getting into november and
that decision had to be in place for the
annual general meeting of the union in
january
and i was we had the support of cole james
from the arctic school at the university
of sydney. And i spoke to col.
Over the telephone long distance
saying i'm having no luck.
And he said yes and we're
running out of time just call.
Sort of offered to sort of do the site
design put his students onto designing the
start of the festival and he said well maybe
we're looking in the wrong direction.
Maybe we should be looking at
the town because if with this.
Like that the cost of putting in the
infrastructure of roads and telephones
and parallel kind of stuff
is going to be enormous
and we don't really have it together so
we think about looking for a village
that we can or something
that has a showground
that we can place the stuff on i think i've
been driving through this place called
niman which is really pretty and it's
got lots of empty shops and a hospital
and looks pretty good.
Sir i went and made enquiries
and made contact with the show
society in the first port of call
and they said we're interested
and we had a meeting famous meeting
called james came up from sydney
and.
We we arranged the time to meet in member
and executive the management committee of
the nimbin agriculture an industrial show
society and i society the agricultural
and industrial society of nim
that were collected around the
war memorial in the main street
and we approached from the
south end of the main street
and walked up the middle of the road and
met them in the middle of the high noon.
I mean we were able to do
those things at 5 p.m..
In the afternoon in the images there's
very little traffic in the street and.
And we went oh i think we would
have in the park back to them.
The park behind woomera
and their position was
that they were interested in the
idea of hosting a festival.
And but i thought it was a major decision
and the town should be involved
in decisions are it was agreed
that we'd have a public meeting and so
we set the date book the home went away
and we came back again
for the public meeting.
That all the publicity we could were away
and in i think it was november
like november and 1970 to.
We had a public meeting we came from
all around the place we made it.
A focal point for planning the festival
and people came down from brisbane people
came across from armidale in sydney
and we came early.
I mean people from the the digger newspaper
in melbourne came up to watch it to see
this public meeting and i'd
arrived a couple of days early.
And spent.
The day of the festival going around
and distributing the
pamphlets about the meeting
and talking to many people i could personally.
So that when we got a meeting about.
Probably as i recall about 200
people in the town hall an emblem.
And.
And it was an extraordinary meeting basically
we'd attracted a lot of extraordinary
people to come to the meeting for
example geico bomber paria who.
At
that time was organizing a group called
harpo which was a kind of the theatre group
come. Consider organizing group
and hope. Food supplier.
Associated with the university of
queensland they had the shop off the campus
but they used to organise
their events on the campus.
And though we approached them to see if
they'd been setting up a few cooperators
part of the festival
and bomb as an extraordinary guy an
extraordinary performer he went on to is a
performer his own rival went
on to sort of produce the.
Flying food fight circus albeit
with longer and he has great lawn.
Pretty hair and sort of thick glasses
and a wry grin and he was there.
Prancing around with a
plastic mallet right.
So is in full performance and if
anyone showed any disaffection
or grumpiness one would creep up behind
them and give them a bop on the head so
that you know. Laughter was produced.
Happy also showed one of the 16 mm.
Movies
that they made which consisted of students
to these guys running around with toilet
paper behind you know
streams of toilet paper.
I don't see in the movie for a shameless
showing a solemn example of the kind of
films with which i'm totally
incomprehensible myself don't know what name
and people. But there was
just a feeling of goodwill
that this was an exciting bunch of people
and the music because we had
live music we perform for them.
I was going to say that this was going to
be something special something different.
So we had a tremendous
amount of goodwill generated
and also we had the support of
the local policeman bob marsh.
And bob marshall was a
policeman with a good heart
and he was concerned about the economic
downturn at neiman the at the at the time
of the festival the school the central
school was threatened with downgrading was
going to become a primary school so even
the people in you know just the first two
years of high school had to travel to
lismore they were talking about closing the
hospital which you know the neiman
community had worked so hard to create
and build in the first place.
And so that the pensioners
and they were people living the town would
have to travel to lismore the services.
And bob was a bit of an entrepreneur
he had on the side he had a.
Sort of recycle pet food business used to
recycle the carcasses in the area dead
cows and dead horses and he wanted to
see more enterprise develop in him
and so he was when we say
well look you chris.
Festival put this town on the map
and you certainly get a lot
of young people moving back.
He was like totally supportive
you know do you think
that helped regenerate nimbin
he was going to support.
So he didn't attend the meeting
but he wrote a letter.
You know to the festival to the
meeting which was read aloud
and it was had the great impact the
impact it had on bob marsh's career as a
policeman was also it's a very good kind
of drummed out of the police force with
being so outspoken. And support.
And the big question was asked of course
inevitably what about drugs and. We.
I remember saying at the time
that the aquarius festival was
not a sunday school picnic.
We're talking about university
students here and. And that marijuana.
Lucia gins were part of the culture
and there's no way we could prevent
that being present at the
festival. And the vote was taken.
It was you know it was like almost unanimous
there only a handful of people i would
say no more than six people who
voted against having the festival.
So we were triumphant. In
fact back down south to the.
To the meeting the annual meeting of the
australian union students and our job.
Was then to get the money for the
budget. You know to get a budget.
As a major event for the student finances.
Well that was the most amazing event
in itself is going to mention
that there are lots of demands lots being
put on the budget of the australian union
of students and.
We worked out that we brought our
entertainers in our singers and dancers
and like our staff when we did them
i spect. Macular presentation.
I remember i wore a dress.
And sparklers i've met people since you
know. The late 80s working in melbourne.
I met a guy in an advertising agency all
your grandsons and i remember i was
that sort of you know wet behind the ears
student politician were going to my first
australian union students conference
and you did this amazing presentation.
It's the best presentation
of ever seen up always well
when i do presentations my clients
are always trying to emulate.
The flair impulse theres a representation.
Anyway what happened was that.
We knock their socks off. Basically and
we had total support for the festival
and we had got through with an open ended
budget over who we had something like
twenty thousand dollars in 1973
money to produce this money
but basic it was open ended.
We could do whatever we needed to do to
get this festival happening which we went
away and did.
So having got the money.
The responsibilities were again split
johnny allen did the spruiking here he was
took the job on of going round
australia talking up the festival
and i had the job of sort of getting
the site organised in nimbin.
And sort of preparing the town for the
strategy we adopted for the publicity was to
work through the student papers and.
We got each with the student papers
at the major campuses to give us
and in addition of the paper which
was the principal i used in 71
and have a guest editor in and.
We filled the paper with stories about
people who are coming to the festival people
giving their raves about
the future. So we had.
Coal james talking about alternative
architecture and low low energy houses
and it was kind of stuff and organic
gardening. You know. So it was.
Always a fascinating array of ideas being
presented. And because we never ever.
We had we had posters funded by
the peter stuyvesant foundation.
It's a bit of an irony at the time.
They never founded the eucharist foundation
again after they found out what the
festivals about.
But basically we didn't use any of the
established many we didn't advertise in them
in the media that television
radio or the press.
And it was only as a very successful
campaign we said you know publicity
that the word of the festival would be
carried on the lips of the counterculture
the people who are really interested in
the light is would tell their friends
and they get together to come and i
remember people scoffing about this
and there is a danger because people carry
negative messages much more readily in
that there is a positive one.
So you got to keep the
vibe really really high
but it was only about three
weeks before the festival
when the first articles appeared in the
sydney morning herald acknowledging
that something strange was happening and
something extraordinary is happening like.
You know the word is out the name of the
place to go to so is a very successful
campaign to court the established
press unawares. And johnny allen.
Was going around australia.
Talking these things up.
He was assisted by a theatre group
that he put together called the white
company which did the same thing in song
and dance and would sing anthems and
create the mood. So we used to.
When the sessions we always finish with
the ritual we burn some incense. Sort of.
Essential oils on charcoal.
Can you know it's.
If you're dealing with
the sort of big temple.
You know it sort of feels there was a breeze
a ball amount of incense who i mean we
deal in melbourne and john pindar. Jump
in the from the last laugh. Come along.
It's got to be on the control.
We actually had to leave
the house below ensign.
And the other thing got out of control was
what company or totally inspirational
but they were all all had their individual
performance troops there a lot of egos
begin sort of bouncing.
Of each other and towards the
end of the tour they got more
and more interested in
primal scream therapy.
The object of the exercise was to invite
the people feeling of the festival
and towards the end of the what companies
promotion the feeling of the festival was
this one's primal scream that for who
exactly is going around school raining.
I had my doubts about whether the
first two promotion at the end
but we got there in the white
company were fantastic. So.
Meanwhile back in nimbin the word got out
and we started up a suit kitchen
which we called the rainbow cafe
and we offered any one who
couldn't afford to pay for people.
Anyone who wanted to work on the
preparation the festival came along
and we would see them
exchange their labour
and in the beginning this
worked wonderfully. And.
Yes we reprinted some some
money in cool name and breads
and an exchange has the name and bread.
If you work the first name and bread.
It gets your food at night and the rain
by cafe itself every evening was like.
A wonderland in a time
when i would sit around with you know
who sat on the floor and low tables.
One of the early countercultural
impacts on a man was
that we say we savage tables we simply can't
a table. We cut its legs of. The fact.
But. We sit on the floor
and we read together
and then we have a talk about the progress
and the festival and then we'd sing
and every night you know there'd be a new
group of people arriving in town these
triple doors and we would be blown
out by the latest performance or
that the latest rave that people come
and say they want to do it was a magical
place in the reputation of the rainbow a
cafe is sort of the cafe of the
universe was sort of built in this.
And what happened for me as an
organizer was this was wonderful p.r.
For the local nimbin community and we
used to invite local businesspeople
and residents.
To come and dine with us
and because they would be blown out to just
it is we finished with a dance everyone
dancing together and holding hands was
canister and wonderful uplifting.
Spiritual experiences and they would
go back and tell their friends
and neighbors
and we had extraordinary goodwill in the
beginning was like magic on the streets
there was a woman who arrived in the
village called margaret sullivan.
Margaret was an irish singer
touring australia at the time
and she was going north and
she decide to detour via name
and because you'd heard about this
place and. Hopped out of the car.
And stayed for seven years.
And she became a welcome.
So that any new face that
arrived in town was. You know.
Margaret go and introduce them and
find a place for most kind of stuff
and she was also a
liaison officer she'd go
and talk to the residents
to find out their concerns.